jurassic world dominion pulls both
heroes and villains from the first
jurassic park movie whether you remember
who they are or not after almost 30
years this jurassic saga is coming to a
close here's everything you need to know
about the end of the second trilogy
the main scheme of biosin ceo louis
dodson a character who first appeared in
an early scene of jurassic park seems to
be as follows use his genetically
engineered locusts to restrict the
world's food supply thereby making every
country dependent on him and his own
locust immune crops unfortunately the
movie doesn't really spend much time
explaining this plan it's mostly
revealed through dr sattler's theories a
few vague allusions to corruption and
one throwaway line from dodson talking
about how he wants control dr henry wu
the original lead geneticist at jurassic
park is the man responsible for the
locusts and he explains that they
actually turned out much stronger than
he planned so it seems that biosin's
plan was to create a scarcity and a
subsequent reliance on their product but
not to such an extreme that global
famine was truly on the table again it
seems that way but there's never any
real dialogue that confirms dodson's
plan it doesn't help that dodson himself
is a bit confusing as the film's main
villain at one point he makes a claim
that money's cheap these days implying
that he's not in the game to get rich
he's already rich after all it's
reasonable to assume men especially
given the franchise's past that his
motivations are strictly egotistical
that he wants to feel like a god but
that assessment also doesn't mesh with
his presentation in the movie it's not
hard to believe that the eccentric
leader of a global technology company is
simply evil power corrupts after all but
dodson's plan seems to lack both a clear
intention and an actual blueprint of how
to pull it all off don't get cheap on me
dodson
fortunately for the world there are
numerous agents within the ranks of
biosin who want nothing more than to
stop dodson's evil scheme in its tracks
the ceo's direct assistant ramsey dr ian
malcolm and dr henry wu are all secretly
working against him with wu in
particular seeking a deeply needed
redemption wu laments that his locusts
are about to bring about the end of
human civilization so he devises a plan
to kill them all in a single swift
stroke maisie the cloned daughter of
jurassic park heiress charlotte lockwood
possesses the answer within her genes
her mother fell victim to a rare and
deadly genetic disease that ultimately
took her life but after cloning maisie
charlotte was able to cure her of the
disorder through a technique that
apparently she never bothered to write
down wu has biosyn kidnap maisie so he
can discern charlotte's method from her
genes which he does in record time
despite his many many past
transgressions the crew decides to help
wu escape from the dinosaur sanctuary so
that he can undo the locust plague a
scene during the film's closing montage
shows him releasing a sample back into
the wild where it joins with the swarm
and supposedly brings about their quick
demise jurassic world dominion doesn't
spend much time addressing wu's other
sins but that may be because the world
seems to have accepted the dinosaurs he
revived as a part of the new order
either way both humans and dinos live to
see another day
once everything starts to fall apart at
the biosin sanctuary maisy and the young
velociraptor beta escape and ellie and
alan steal a dna sample of the
engineered locusts dodson decides to
call the whole thing off and start over
he tries to burn the remaining locusts
to remove the evidence of biosin's
involvement in the famine but the flying
beasts escape and soar over the dino
sanctuary delivering a biblical plague
of flaming locusts on the prehistoric
world it's an undeniably striking
addition to the film's climax as the
fiery bugs rain from the sky like it's
the end of the world the whole sequence
smacks of the dinosaur's original
extinction event by design fortunately
the dinosaurs themselves don't all die
out this time as they've herded into a
protected area to wait out the blaze for
all its visual appeal the swarm of
flaming locusts doesn't actually end up
having that much impact on the story of
jurassic world dominion but hey it sure
looks cool
dodgson
dodson we've got dodson here lewis
dodson experiences some big comeuppance
for his villainous ways first in the
decimation of his kingdom which is
largely his own fault and then by a
poetical death at the hands of one of
the franchise's most iconic dinosaurs
once it becomes clear that the situation
at the sanctuary isn't fixable dodson
prepares for a quick getaway he asks
ramsay to come with him and claims that
they can start over somewhere new only
to discover that his assistant is the
one who orchestrated his destruction
enraged dodson heads out on his own via
the facility's train tunnels for a
moment it looks as if the evil mogul
might actually make it out but a
strategic power outage by the film's
heroes freezes his train and its tracks
when dodson attempts to get out and walk
he's accosted by a squad of
dilophosauruses who bring his life to an
abrupt and violent end this death is
particularly symbolic as it's the same
fate that befalls dennis nedry in the
original jurassic park dodson is the one
who commissioned nedry to steal embryos
from injen so he's also technically the
one responsible for the original crisis
at the park there's even a shot in the
film of what appears to be nedry's fake
barbasol can in dodson's office which
dodson takes with him on the ill-fated
escape implying that somehow he managed
to locate the sight of nedry's death and
bring the embryos back
though the early parts of the movie are
more akin to globetrotting action flicks
like fast and furious jurassic park
dominion eventually settles into the
series tried and true formula of
stranding all the main characters in the
middle of a dinosaur park malcolm
sattler grant owen maisie claire pilot
kayla watts and eventually wu all meet
up in dolomite sanctuary where they have
to fight for their lives to escape the
encroaching beasts dominion takes
advantage of the situation to deliver
some cute moments between the different
characters such as owen telling grant
that he read his book a reference to the
original film and clarenelli bonding
over their respective dino traumas this
climactic team up also includes a number
of parallels to earlier films in the
series claire and ellie have to adjust
the sanctuary's power in a dark corridor
reminiscent of the powershed from
jurassic park dr grant brings his
decades of velociraptor research to bear
in helping owen and maisie safely rescue
beta in a moment that while surely a bit
triggering is also probably pretty cool
for the seasoned paleontologist and of
course kayla gets the whole crew out
safely via helicopter the only proper
way to escape from jurassic park
what is that
it wouldn't be a jurassic park movie
without some dino on dino action and
dominion delivers just that in the form
of a climactic duel between the t-rex
and the giganotosaurus their battle is
foreshadowed earlier in the film and it
finally takes place just as the human
crew is about to make their final
getaway as they run for kayla's chopper
the two primordial behemoths rampage
around them decimating the area and
delivering some brutal blows just when
it looks like the giganotosaurus has the
t-rex dead to rights though the humans
intervene for their own reasons and give
the fan favorite dino a chance at a
second wind would the giganotosaurus
have won had the humans not intervened
probably but given all the times the
t-rex has saved them in previous films
it only seems right that they lend a
helping hand in return there are some
truths in the jurassic world that can
never be undone and one of those is that
no matter how big the competition the
t-rex will always reign supreme
if you came to jurassic world dominion
to see a conclusion to a three decades
long will they won't they arc between
alan grant and ellie sattler you're
probably in the minority but you're also
in luck the on-screen chemistry between
sam neil and laura dern remains
excellent in dominion and the screenplay
spends a good amount of time on their
middle aged romance ellie establishes
early on that her kids first shown in
jurassic park 3 are grown and that she's
divorced from her former husband by
contrast grant has been doing classic
grant things living a solitary life
digging up dinosaur bones
you comment or what
the circumstances under which these two
characters come back together make sense
and the adorably awkward scenes of them
navigating their relationship are some
of the film's true highlights it's fun
and not terribly common to see two
characters of their age working through
their feelings for each other in the
middle of a bombastic action movie and
it's very satisfying to see them finally
get together at the end of the story
despite the evils of biosin's leader it
seems that the organization has done
some legitimately good things in the
interest of dinosaur safety and
preservation the biggest example of this
at least by square footage is the dino
sanctuary in the dolomites which
continues to operate as a refuge for the
creatures even after all the terrible
events of the film while some dinosaurs
are shown to still be roaming free in
other parts of the world in the final
sequence a large number of them are
happily relocated to the dolomites where
they're safe from humans and where
humans are safe from them oddly enough
this is sort of a new jurassic park
albeit one that foregoes many of the
inherent dangers and problems of the
original and of jurassic world in a real
world era when natural preservation and
wildlife sanctuaries are becoming highly
supported and in which the sentiment
toward for-profit zoos and animal
captivity in general has thankfully
plummeted it's interesting to see a
dinosaur sanctuary being presented as a
sort of happy ending for the franchise
john hammond was a showman and a
businessman so he probably wouldn't have
chosen such an isolated location for the
animals he helped revive but given all
that he saw happen as a result of his
hubris it's possible that he would have
quite liked the idea of the dinos in the
dolomites
of course not every living dinosaur
willingly relocates to the sanctuary in
italy at the end of jurassic world
dominion one of the film's most striking
sequences comes at the very end a
montage of shots from all across the
globe that show how dinosaurs are
starting to become part of the modern
earth ecosystem pteranodons are shown
taking flight alongside ordinary birds
triceratops roam the blistering savannah
alongside herds of elephants even the
fearsome mosasaurus swims peacefully
alongside whales who look puny by
comparison this majestic look at the new
world order ends the film on a positive
and optimistic note suggesting that all
the perceived dangers of reborn
dinosaurs can be managed if humans adopt
a perspective of harmony and progress
it's a nice sentiment and certainly a
lovely note to end the film on but is it
realistic consider this most of the
jurassic world trilogy has been spent
building up to this moment of dinosaurs
repopulating in the wild throughout the
entire franchise it's always been
foreshadowed as a dangerous event and
yet dominion seems to brush it off by
the end most of the film is spent
addressing the locust problem with no
real attention paid to the effects the
dinos themselves will have in fact the
world is basically the same at the end
of the movie as it is at the very
beginning none of the dyno problems have
been solved unless you count a sweetly
worded monologue from a dead scientist
as a solution surely planet earth still
has a lot to work out with its new
denizens roaming free
experience the epic conclusion of the
jurassic era that's the tagline that
appears in the official trailer for
jurassic world dominion and the film
definitely feels like a swan song from
the return of sam neal and laura dern to
the closing scenes of dino's re-entering
nature there's a sense that this is
meant to be the climactic wrap-up to the
entire series but is it really the
jurassic franchise has raked in a ton of
cash over the decades and it's become
one of universal's most lucrative brands
it has not only been a juggernaut for
ticket sales but for merchandising as
well after all kids will always love
dinosaurs on top of the business reasons
to keep the movies going there are a lot
of easy ways to keep the story going new
characters like ramsay and kayla are
arguably some of the best parts of
jurassic world dominion so even if the
franchise's long time stars are finished
there are plenty of folks who could
still return with dinosaurs now roaming
the globe there are an infinite number
of potential storylines to be cooked up
to keep the adventure rolling forward
whether or not that's actually a good
idea from a creative standpoint is
another matter entirely some might say
that the original film should never have
become a series in the first place as
most of the subsequent installments have
been critically panned maybe like the
dinosaurs jurassic park shouldn't be
brought back to the land of the living
perhaps the time has come to let this
franchise go extinct
see not so bad
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]